bonjour monsieur
donc nous poursuivons cet après-midi les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
par l'audition de Monsieur Wilson Savino
ça Rino dit non ça finit
sale vino conseiller pour la coopération
avec les institutions scientifiques et
technologiques françaises de la
Fondation brésilienne
Oswaldo Cruz
je vous remercie tout d'abord d'avoir
accepté et d'être de vous être mobilisé
aujourd'hui la Fondation Oswaldo Cruz
occupe une place singulière dans le
système de santé brésilien c'est aussi
pour ça que ça nous intéressait de vous
entendre fonder en 1900 sous le nom
d'institus sérologiques fédéral elle
contribue à la production et à la
diffusion de connaissances et de
technologie dans le but consolider le
système universel de santé au Brésil et
de contribuer à la promotion de la santé
et de la qualité de la vie de la
population elle contribue aussi et c'est
ce qui nous intéresse avant tout
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on avait
organisé qu'on a organisé cette audition
à la fabrication de médicaments
stratégiques pour le système de santé
notamment avec le laboratoire
pharmandinios situé à Rio de Janeiro
voilà notre présidente vous nous
indiquerez plus précisément quels sont
les médicaments produits par votre
fondation et comment ils sont
sélectionnés par le ministère fédéral de
la santé ou d'autres entités publiques
plus largement la production publique de
médicaments
occupe au Brésil une place importante
grâce au rôle des nombreux laboratoires
officiels qui se partagent la production
des produits figurants sur la liste
nationale des médicaments essentiels
c'est aussi c'est une problématique qui
nous intéresse vous pourrez nous
indiquer comment l'activité de la
Fondation s'articule avec celle des
laboratoires officiels et nous vous
interrogerons également sur le périmètre
des activités de production publique
lorsque celle-ci couvrent les seuls
étapes de formulation ou de
conditionnement les risques
d'approvisionnement en principe actifs
qui peuvent demeurer important enfin
peut-être pourrez-vous plus largement
nous présenter un panorama des
politiques publiques mises en œuvre au
Brésil pour assurer l'approvisionnement
des médicaments puisque c'est le thème
même de notre commission d'enquête que
celle-ci consiste ou non à recourir aux
capacités de production des laboratoires
officiels et de la Fondation je pense
notamment au réglementation ou au
contrat destiné à inciter ou contraindre
les laboratoires privés laboratoire
privé pardon et à sécuriser
l'approvisionnement du marché brésilien
des médicaments l'ensemble de ces
éléments sont susceptibles d'éclairer
les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête et plus largement les
réflexions en cours dans notre pays sur
l'établissement d'une liste de
médicaments critiques et sur la
sécurisation de leur approvisionnement
je vais vous céder la parole pour un
propos introductif après avoir laissé le
micro à notre présidente puis madame
Laurence Cohen notre rapporteur vous
posera une première série de questions
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues c'est valable aussi
pour les
aux articles 434 13 30 434 434 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à donc
prêter serment et à dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
merci donc je vais les céder la parole à
notre président
et nous allons vous écouter
je vous en prie vous pouvez prendre la
parole
et tout d'abord bon je m'appelle Wilson
Savino
en fait je suis chercheur
et à la base je suis émunologiste
je fais une bonne partie de ma formation
à Paris en fait
une partie en équerre
assure-toi Necker mais après j'étais
profité non seulement un magazine à la
Pitié-Salpêtrière donc j'ai une longue
collaboration avec la France de plus de
40 ans en fait
comme chercheur
et depuis quelques temps
je travaille pour la théorie dans le
domaine de la coopération avec la France
que je vais en parler un petit peu
là-dessus donc ce que je ferais pour
comme introduction une partie a été
faite déjà sur Le Fur creuse sur la
quand on dit fondation genre de creuses
on peut dire fiocrus qui a connu comme
ça non seulement au Brésil mais même
ailleurs compris l'Amérique l'Amérique
latine etc bon alors cette diapo
n'allons pas donc cette diapo elle
montre déjà une chose importante c'est
que la fiocrousse est une institution
stratégique
de l'État pour la santé
et ça c'est important parce que
de plus en plus la course devient
stratégique pour l'État et donc nous
avons maintenant une condition
[Musique]
on pourrait dire idéal
ou très bonne je fête que l'ex
présidente de la fiocrousse madame
nisiatringdad et actuellement la
ministre de la Santé
et donc avant de parler de la Focus de
la prochaine diapositive je voudrais
juste vous rappeler ce qui était encore
une fois déjà annoncé que la fur creuse
elle s'insère dans un système initié de
santé dans le système universel
il faut rappeler que le Brasil ayant une
population de 120 millions de personnes
autour de
70 à 75% de tous les individus au Brésil
s'utilisent exclusivement du système
public unifié de santé
c'est un système le plus grand au monde
pour un seul système pour un seul pays
quand je parle de public alors que entre
25 et 30% de la population brésilienne
utilise en plus ce système public
utilise aussi un système supplémentaire
privé mais de toute façon ce qui est
important
là dedans et
ça savait ensemble avec le fait que la
furrence est une institution stratégique
c'est le fait que dans la Constitution
brésilienne
la santé ça écrit comme ça la santé
étant droit du citoyen et un devoir de
l'État
ce qui est très bien
et que ça pose des problèmes économiques
qui sont pas négligeables vu les prix
des médicaments de plus en plus cher
surtout des médicaments pour thérapie
génique etc qui coûte de plus en plus
cher mais en tout cas en ce qui concerne
la population brésilienne c'est très
important que ce soit écrit dans cette
constitution de
1988 après la dictature militaire qu'on
a vécu pendant 21 ans que la santé est
en droit du citoyen et de voir l'état
s'il vous plaît donc
ça c'est la marque de la fiocross c'est
un
symbole qui a été conçu sur le plan du
croquis par Monsieur zan de Cruz
et cette fondation de ça ça a été basé
sur
une synagogue à New York il a à yendre à
Lyon
en Espagne
mais il y a aussi des gargouilles donc
c'est on peut on mélange et ça a été
fait par
un architecte portugais mais basé sur
les croquis de CROUS donc cette bâtiment
était inauguré en 1908
et la fille aux a été créée la prochaine
diapositive je pense qu'on peut voir ça
elle était créée en 1900 comme une
fondation publique donc
monsieur zorroïde
à Pasteur
et quand elle était invitée par le
gouvernement pour créer
pour créer cette institut
national il a fait
sur les bases de l'Institut Pasteur
c'est-à-dire
recherche production enseignement
mais il a eu quand même une différence
importante c'est que Louis Pasteur n'a
pas pu faire un institut public
alors que au Brésil la fondation de Cruz
est publique depuis toujours
c'est à dire que nous appartenons au
ministère de la Santé du Brésil
et donc du fait qu'elle a publié
la mission c'est de diffuser et partager
des connaissances et des technologies
visant au renforcement et la
considération de système inutile de
santé du Brésil qu'on appelle Suisse
et contribuer à la promotion de la santé
et la qualité de vie de la population
comme ça a été déjà
dit tout à l'heure mais en plus de ça
étant donné que le Brésil depuis très
très très longtemps et tant pis
inégalités importantes
c'est dans la mission de la fibrousse
réduire les inégalités sociales avec la
défense du droit à la santé et à la vie
bien entendu et à la plaine citoyenneté
comme valeur centrale
et c'est ça qui on essaye de faire tous
les jours
ce qui est quand même pas banal d'une
part très difficile mais on essaye je
vais quand même vous en parler un petit
peu sur les effets qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait pendant la pandémie parce que je
cru comprendre aussi que
ça serait important au relevant que je
parle un peu comment comment la fureuse
a pris
position et après l'importance vis-à-vis
de ce qui s'est passé au Brésil durant
la pandémie du covid 19 or il y a quand
même une chose très importante de la
furiose c'est que elle est une
institution nationale c'est-à-dire que
les bases les quartiers généraux sont à
Rio mais on a des unités de recherche
presque partout au Brésil ce qui nous
donne une force de frappe au niveau
national bien plus importantes que
c'était seulement à Rio donc on dit plus
en plus on déploie des expériences
nationales et locales à la fois
et ça
surtout dans le 2 dernières crises
sanitaire importante que Brésil que le
Brésil a vécu d'abord Zika entre 2015 et
2016 qui a été
très dur pour la société brésilienne
puis après puis après covid 19 le fait
d'avoir une institution nationale avec
des unités de recherche et il a pensé
critique il a pensé stratégique
distribuée au Brésil y compris à
Brasilia où nous avons un bureau
d'intelligence
qui est
en communication directe avec le
gouvernement y compris le Parlement
d'ailleurs
et puis quand j'avais dit donc il y a
des unités de recherche on peut partout
au Brésil mais
il y a une petite bulle
bleue qui est biomanking
qui sont des unités de production
farmingus produit des médicaments
et en particulier produit les génériques
qui sont importants pour plusieurs
maladies
du genre diabète hypertension
et d'autres et aussi des antirétroviraux
et puis
je vais en parler un peu plus qui
produit
des petits diagnostics
des vaccins
et ce qu'on appelle
bio pharmaceutique donc de
médicaments déjà biologiques et pas de
synthèse
à la prochaine
or il y a quand même une chose c'est que
la Fio Cruz
la fiocrose
on est en train de développer de plus en
plus en système de pour
internationaliser le feu rouge
et une des actions qui a lieu en ce
moment même c'est
l'établissement d'une plateforme
scientifique sur CROUS Institut Pasteur
à la surcrose dans l'état du Ciara au
nord-est du Brésil
et une autre action qui a avoir avec la
France si aussi c'est que nous sommes en
train d'établir un doctorat conjoint
entre sur CROUS et Sorbonne université
je pas dire mais je dirais tout de suite
et je vais revenir après la fiocrousse
n'étant pas du tout une université elle
est quand même agréée par le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale pour délivrer
des diplômes des masters et doctorats
donc avec ça on fait partie du tout le
système d'enseignement supérieur
des niveaux Master Doctorat
la prochaine s'il vous plaît et bon ça
c'est juste pour vous dire que cette
coopération avec la France c'est quand
même pas au hasard que la fille aux
courses déploie une personne pour
s'occuper de ça c'est que est une
coopération très importante
même qu'on comparé au monde entier
et avec des accords qui non seulement
qui ont été signés mais surtout que ça
désaccord qui marche avec par exemple
une serre le CNRS la sorbanne l'Institut
Pasteur
le réseau international des institution
pasteur je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais la fille Rose en fait
partie et puis
nous sommes en train d'établir aussi la
prochaine
je suis avec la Fondation merveilleux
une autre collaboration donc cette
collaboration avec la France elle date
depuis le début
du fait que pasteur était stagiaire
pardon que c'était stagiaire à Pasteur
et donc ça continue de façon très
importante prochaine s'il vous plaît
mais la Focus de plus en plus surtout
maintenant avec
la pandémie de covid 19 la fée CROUS
d'Évian a juste titre d'ailleurs un
acteur de santé globale et c'est quand
même pas au hasard qu'elle fait partie
de plusieurs
groupes de travail au niveau de santé
global
prochaine s'il vous plaît
bon alors je vais passer un peu en
vitesse ça mais nous avons toute une
planète panoplie de des thématiques de
recherche c'est un institut très
important faut savoir que nous sommes
13.000 personnes dont la moitié
employée publique et la moitié en CDI
par des contrats que la fille aux creuse
mette avec des entreprises privées mais
toutes les recherches sont des
fonctionnaires publics par exemple
et donc il y a de il y a une histoire
des maladies infectieuses qui restent
comme ça des santé publique faut dire
que le système unifié de santé du Brésil
a été conçu en fait à la cycose au début
des années 80
prochaine s'il vous plaît et puis depuis
quelques années depuis kinise la
l'ex-présidente a commencé son premier
mandat on a décidé de déployer une
partie de du budget de la fille aux
CROUS pour faire des financements de
projets intra-muros c'est à dire que en
plus du système brésilien qui existe
pour
apprivois pour mettre de l'argent à
partir des appels à projets que ça soit
au niveau du ministère de la Santé que
ça soit au niveau du ministère de
sciences technologique et même ministère
de l'Éducation nationale la Focus a
décidé de faire
ce programme qu'on appelle innova fiorus
qui est un programme qui favorise la
recherche le développement
technologiques l'innovation dans tous
les domaines visant à fournir des
produits directement à la société
brésilienne et là quand dans cette
phrase le terme produit ça veut dire non
seulement quelque chose dont on peut
toucher mais aussi la production des
connaissances
qui soit utile pour la société donc en
plus des centres de recherche il y a
aussi
à coupler à ce centre de recherche
quelques hôpitaux pour des maladies
infectieuses en institut national
d'infectologie à Rio en institut
national de santé de la mère de l'enfant
et de l'adolescent
et des centres de soins primaires
c'est-à-dire que dans l'écosystème de la
fiocrosse on a à la fois la recherche la
production je vais je vais en revenir et
la santé dans le sens vraiment de soins
de santé directement dirigé à la
population
prochaine s'il vous plaît
et là je
veux parler un petit peu de cette unité
de production qui s'appelle biomangings
c'est pas l'unité qui produit le
médicament de synthèse mais c'est
l'unité qui produit des kit diagnostic
qui produit
de bio pharmaceutique comme j'avais dit
et qui est produit des vaccins je
voudrais en parler un petit peu plus et
à la prochaine diapositive donc juste
pour que vous pouvez avoir une idée donc
au niveau du vaccin on produit 13
vaccins différents pour la société
brésilienne alors là je fais une
parenthèse pour dire que le programme
national des minimisation au Brésil et
un de plus important au monde sur le
plan de couvrir
avant la pandémie
entre 95 et 98% de la population
maintenant avec la pandémie ça diminuer
et ça et ça ça a été dû à tout ce qui a
été dit dans le monde et le Brésil
n'était pas du tout une exception mais
on revient maintenant avec une
progression
vers l'adhésion massive du peuple
brésilien à l'immunisation et là il faut
quand même dire que nous avons au Brésil
deux institutions qui produisent des
vaccins
qui est responsable pour
65% de la production
totale de vaccins
et
l'Institut Boutin qui est en institut de
recherche et des productions de l'état
de 100 Paolo et qui produit quelque
chose comme 35%
des vaccins donc le programme de
l'immunisation au Brésil
très bien et
celle biomanking selfie au creuse qui
produit la majeure partie des vaccins
que
ceux qui sont délivrés au système au
système de santé
mais si on va de l'autre côté de la
diapositive on a des anticorps
monoclonaux et d'autres
biofarmatusotiques qui sont produits
aussi plus récemment par la furros et ça
on développe à partir de quelques années
et on va développer encore davantage à
partir de cette année
toute une une échelle de production
de bio pharmaceutique
pour
sol la thérapie en utilisant des
anticoramono qui coûtent très cher et la
Focus produit déjà pour la clinique pour
les malades mais nous aurons à partir de
maintenant un énorme programme qui va
démarrer
1 2 3 mois
pour la thérapie c'est le l'air thérapie
génique
surtout pour des maladies rares parce
que comme vous le savez les maladies
elles sont rares mais elles sont très
coûteuses sur le plan du système de
santé de n'importe quel pays
et notre idée c'est que la fille aux
CROUS et je répète une situation
stratégique de l'État
puisse prendre en charge
la capacité des production de un certain
nombre de médicaments ou bien une
certaine un certain nombre de méthodes
comme par exemple peut-être que vous
connaissez déjà la méthode de curticell
pour les pour les
cancers par exemple
d'ailleurs on commence à faire ça pas à
faire encore carte Cell mais monter les
structures pour ça
et puis la biomanisme produit aussi
toute une série de kits diagnostics pour
cette
large panoplie
des agents infectieux qui s'assoient des
kits
diagnostics sérologique ce qui se sera
par PCR et je reviendrai là-dessus tout
de suite prochaine s'il vous plaît bon
là je ne sais pas si vous lisez
bien personnellement moi je n'ai pas
bien
d'ici mais je peux vous lire quand même
parce que ça vaut le coup de lire deux
ou trois choses et ça veut dire moi je
parle
de la participation qui a été presque
une intervention de la fille aux CROUS
au moment de la pandémie
et nous nous sommes réunis et nous avons
monté une cellule de crise
en fin janvier 2020 même même pas vers
le vent de janvier 2020
il y en a décidé de
prendre quelques initiatives différentes
une initiative de support diagnostic
c'est à dire que en février 2020 fin
février 2020 la fille aux creuse a
commencé à produire des kits TCR
pour distribuer dans le système de santé
brésilien un mois
parce que bien entendu on avait déjà une
mise en place de la technique etc
mais ça a été très important et je dois
dire que ça a été aussi important non
seulement pour le Brésil mais pour
quelques pays de l'Amérique du Sud et à
travers un projet
financé par le Mercosur on a pu fournir
faire en fait des donations
au système de santé au Paraguay et ça a
été très important pour les Paraguay à
ce moment-là d'avoir on a fait donation
de 50000 kits diagnostic par PCR au
pingouin et ça ça a été ça a été
vraiment
important pour
pour ce pays là
donc on a créé un réseau de génomique et
ça c'est je vais revenir là-dessus mais
on a fait donc
support diagnostic soins de santé à
travers la création d'un hôpital
pour 200 lits dans la moitié sans
intensif en 68 jours il s'épan hôpital
campagne
développement des connaissances sciences
technologies innovation
toute une partie d'information et
communication qui est qui est absolument
essentiel ça a été essentiel pour
naviguer contre les fake news qui qui
débordait tous les jours de partout
et donc cette
cette initiative était très importante
une autre initiative importante qui a
été faite dans quelques régions du
Brésil mais pas trop parce que c'était
pas possible c'était le support aux
populations plus vulnérables
et à côté de ça toute la formation de
personnel de gens des jeunes
à la fiouse à l'extérieur de la fureuse
à partir d'éducation à distance on a
formé des milliers de gens et donc ce
panel là il montre de deux ans de
travail du beaucoup de gens mais qui
était
je vous dirais que sans le système
unifié de santé
j'ajoute essence le Brésil aurait passé
par une crise beaucoup plus grave que
celle qui a été qui nous a frappé de
toute façon
s'il vous plaît
et donc ça c'est l'hôpital qui a été
alors l'histoire de cet hôpital il a été
décidé très très vite parce qu'il
manquait le système de le système de
santé ne supportait pas à Rio donc ça a
été créé sur un terrain de foot qui
était à l'intérieur du campus de la
fibreuse
et ça a été créé en 70 jours
et je dis ça
je mets et le bâtiment et le personnel
mille personnes quand même qui ont
travaillé et qui travaillent encore
maintenant c'est un hôpital qui est
relié au système de santé de la ville de
Rio de l'état des Rio plutôt et qui
permet que
des soins de très bonne qualité dans le
à l'intérieur du campus
s'il vous plaît bon ça c'est l'hôpital
je passe vite
alors ça c'est important je sais pas
lire juste la partie la partie
à gauche c'est le fait que en février
nous a confié la référence dans les
Amériques pour covid
en février 2020 nous avons fait un cours
international pour l'Amérique latine
financé par l'EPS
pour diagnostic moléculaire de covid et
ça ça a été
en février 2020
s'il vous plaît
donc la coordonnée toute une partie de
et cordienne encore de clinique et
cliniques c'est-à-dire que le fait qu'il
y en a des systèmes de recherche couplés
à des hôpitaux nous permet de faire et
du prix clinique et du clinique
et par exemple la fille aux Crous a été
la
coordinatrice d'un grand essai clinique
menée par l'OMS pour covid
et du côté du Brésil c'est un essai
mondial
et du côté du Brésil c'était coordonné
par la secousse parce qu'il y a cette
organisation elle avait déjà cette
organisation bien entendu prochaine s'il
vous plaît
alors là donc on a je viens au vaccin
anti covid parce que ça ça a été ça a
été une différence importante peut-être
que ça peut ça peut être utile ce que si
je vous raconte un petit peu comment ça
s'est passé au Brésil
en étant donné qu'il y a des unités de
production au Brésil publique de vaccins
comme j'avais dit l'Institut vous
tentant
une entité fédérale
un bout en temps a décidé
de faire un transfert de technologie
d'un vaccin qui a été produit en Chine à
partir du virus
et la fièvre Cruz a fait une prospection
et a fait un autre choix
qui était de discuter pour faire un
transfert de technologie avec
l'université d'auxifore à travers
la grande boîte pharmaceutique à ça
alors cette ce transfert des
technologies
était le seul du genre qui est
astrazenika a fait dans le monde
c'est-à-dire que ils ont transféré non
seulement
ce qu'on appelle l'ingrédient
pharmaceutique active ils ont transféré
tout c'est à dire que nous sommes 100%
autonome pour produire
de le l'ingrédient pharmaceutique active
jusqu'au petit flacon qui sera distribué
dans le système de santé et ça répond à
une question tout ce que la fille au
cours produit elle produit déjà le
flacon pour les systèmes de santé que ce
soit des vaccins des kits
des produits pharmaceutiques des
synthèses auprès de synthèse
donc on a on a déjà distribué ça c'était
un peu ancien donc c'est on est à 250
millions de doses de accent qui ont été
distribués dans le système de santé
brésilien
et ça ça a sauvé des milliers de vie ça
je peux vous garantir ça et quand je dis
je peux vous garantir ça va parce que je
suis garant quelque chose c'est parce
que ça a été étudié
toutes les estimatives ont été étudiées
sous le plan scientifique qui ont
démontré ça
et
donc l'incorporation de la technologie
est totale pour la production de ce
vaccins mais aussi l'incorporation c'est
à dire que maintenant on a les
conditions de faire
ce genre de technologie
pourquoi on a parce que la cause avait
déjà une usine de production de sang ça
pas été créé du jour au lendemain ça a
pas été créé à partir de la pandémie et
c'est pas au hasard qu'elle a fait au
creuse a été choisie maintenant
récemment par l'OMS comme un des rabes
des productions futures de vaccins à RNA
ARN messager
ça c'est parce que nous avons la
capacité de machines et des personnels
pour le faire
s'il vous plaît donc une autre chose qui
a été fait aussi
dans le cadre de la pandémie c'était une
un réseau génomique pour pouvoir
regarder presque en temps réel les
mouvements des variantes de virus qui
circulaient au Brésil y compris la
détection de la variante qui a qui est
paru en Amazonie
s'il vous plaît
le soutien aux populations vénérable
j'avais y compris les favelas mais pas
que population carcérale par exemple
donc
les populations rurales rurales et
d'origine noire des esclaves le cul qui
sont des populations très très
vulnérables
notre chaîne s'il vous plaît et je suis
en train de presque finir je sais que
c'est un peu long mais je voudrais quand
même vous donner une idée
du d'un réseau qui
qui
prend un pays de 2000 de 2 millions de
220 millions de personnes donc l'édition
c'est de renforcer les investissements
continuent dans la science technologies
innovation et ça c'est très important
pour nous ça a été très important pour
nous parce que ça nous montre
qui ont venait dans
un processus
dont l'investissement sciences
technologies et même l'investissement
santé
était en baisse
et il y en aurait pas
les bases de préparation pour cette
pandémie on aurait pas su faire tout ce
qui a été fait
de toute façon
c'est priorités
les activités de recherche et
développement et d'innovation dans le
domaine biomédical et quand je parle
d'innovation ça peut être
une méthode très compliquée et ça peut
être en applicative de portable qui peut
être très très utile aussi encore une
fois c'est un pays énorme 13 hétérogène
dans le plan social mais aussi dans le
plan géographique et donc ça c'est cette
communication directe
pour vous dire que nous avons fait un
appel à projet que pour développement
d'applicatif pour covid on appelle un
projet intra-muros
et bien entendu les besoins d'engagement
social et je termine pour vous dire que
la fille aux CROUS est reconnue
par le peuple brésiliens c'était avant
c'était déjà avant la pandémie et
maintenant c'est bien plus comme
l'institution publique plus fiable au
Brésil parmi toutes
voilà merci
très bien
m'excuser de mon temps je vous remercie
beaucoup pour cette présentation
extrêmement complète et qui qui montre
un
système de santé intégré de la recherche
jusqu'à la production en passant par la
prise en charge sanitaire et le rôle de
d'assurance maladie en quelque sorte je
vais tout de suite passer la parole à
Laurence Cohen pour
une série de questions
oui alors merci aussi beaucoup pour
votre présentation moi je tenais je
tenais effectivement à ce que on puisse
auditionner la fiocruz parce que j'ai
j'ai eu la chance et le privilège
d'aller plusieurs fois au Brésil et
d'aller visiter cette cette fondation et
tout dernièrement avec le groupe
d'amitié France-Brésil donc que je
préside j'ai pu rencontrer la présidente
alors j'ai pas très bien le prononcer
mes tridades
Nicia tridad et je crois que que c'est
vraiment une chance qu'elle soit
aujourd'hui
ministre de la Santé quand je l'ai
rencontré en mars 2022 elle était
présidente de la de la Fondation elle
est ministre pourquoi je dis c'est une
chance parce que effectivement vous
l'avez souligné le Brésil enfin la
population brésilienne j'allais dire
contrairement à la population française
et très convaincue du bien fondé
notamment des vaccins et il y a une
couverture vaccinale au Brésil qui est
extrêmement importante mais avec ce qui
s'est dit dans le monde mais pas
seulement ce qui s'est dit dans le monde
ce qui s'est passé
au niveau gouvernemental sur la mise en
question de du virus de l'efficacité du
vaccin il y a eu un certain nombre de
scepticisme
et du coup il y a eu un petit peu moins
de on va dire d'engouement pour la
vaccination ça c'est la première chose
et la deuxième chose aussi c'est qu'il y
a eu un choix politique de délaisser les
populations alors vous dites les
populations vulnérables mais je pense
particulièrement à toute la zone
amazonienne où il a fallu que la justice
s'en mêle pour qu'on puisse vacciner les
populations alors une fois que j'ai
juste dit ça nous on est intéressé par
vous entendre parce que on voit bien que
on a vécu ça fait un moment que l'on vit
en France mais en Europe dans le monde
des tensions des pénuries de médicaments
que le covid a exacerbé les choses mais
que on voit que tous les médicaments
sont touchés anticancéreux antiviraux
antibiotiques en fait etc pilule amorti
à chaque fois on est sur de nouveaux
médicaments qui sont touchés et au
niveau de notre commission à la fois on
fait un état des lieux mais ça on peut
se mettre très vite d'accord sur l'état
des lieux mais on a aussi envie de
d'ouvrir des pistes des recommandations
pour justement sortir de cette de cette
situation qui ne fait que s'aggraver
puisque on en est maintenant à au moins
cas signalés de tension etc alors que
ça a été multiplié par quatre en très
très peu de temps
donc l'expérience du Brésil qui est
quand même une expérience ancienne et on
voit bien que à la fois il y a vous avez
c'est vraiment intégré dans le système
de santé c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
la recherche la production
le fait de pouvoir parce que c'est le
Brésil c'est un très très grand pays une
forte population est un très grand pays
il faut aussi fournir aux quatre coins
c'est du du Brésil donc vous avez tout
ça vous avez créé tout ça et c'est par
rapport à ce même si un modèle n'est pas
duplicable obligatoirement c'est avoir
aussi votre point de vue sur un certain
nombre de choses et par moi j'aimerais
vous interroger sur le fait que
vous avez en tout cas au niveau de la
fiocrues me semble-t-il une capacité de
production qui tourne autour à peu près
de 2,5 milliards d'unités de médicaments
par an
et il y a 35 références de médicaments
qui sont produits par le laboratoire et
donc ils concernent des anti-infectieux
dont plusieurs antiviraux etc etc je
vais pas donc évidemment je peux pas
taire un élément important parce que
tout vient aussi de là c'est le
traitement de l'infection par le VIH et
les hépatites virales etc donc vous avez
vous avez ça je voudrais savoir
aujourd'hui par rapport au fait que il y
a vous comment dirais-je vous importez
un certain nombre de matières premières
semblent-ils est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
visé touché justement vous aussi par la
difficulté de vous approvisionner en
matière première et donc de pouvoir
produire un certain nombre de
médicaments donc est-ce que vous êtes
vous aussi touché par les pénuries et
comment finalement vous pouvez vous
pouvez y répondre ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question c'est
finalement
quand je dis vous il y a 35 références à
la fois c'est beaucoup mais il y en a
d'autres des références donc en fait
quels sont les médicaments
finalement qui sont sélectionnés pour
être produit par les laboratoires
publics et quels critères vous prenez
vous prenez en compte pour choisir ses
médicaments ces médicaments là
ça c'est ma deuxième ma deuxième
question et comment vous vous arrivez à
sécuriser vos productions
contenues de ce qui se passe au niveau
au niveau mondial et donc des pressions
du marché puisque le médicament est
considéré hélas de mon point de vue
comme une marchandise mais
c'est considéré comme une marchandise au
niveau mondial et donc il y a une
fluctuation par rapport au marché donc
comment vous vous arrivez à sécuriser
votre votre production et finalement
peut-être nous donner un peu plus
d'éléments de détails sur le fait que si
j'ai bien compris la fille aux Cruz donc
à la capacité de recherche de production
etc
vous néanmoins si j'ai bien vu sur les
diapositives il doit y avoir 30 ou 35%
qui sont faits par des laboratoires
privés donc quel type de contrat vous
passez avec ces laboratoires privés
comment est-ce que ça ça se passe et
ma toute dernière question c'est est-ce
que la la Fondation produit des
médicaments qui continuent à être
protégés par un brevet
je vous remercie pour vos réponses par
avance monsieur Wilson vous avez la
parole
vous notez les questions
je vais commencer par une réflexion bien
plus générale
qui n'était pas dans vos questions mais
à mon avis font partie comme ça fait
partie de vos questions
c'est qu'est-ce que le rôle de l'État
vis-à-vis la santé
et à partir de là pourquoi
ne pas prendre la responsabilité d'État
pour garantir la santé d'une population
là et là je reviens avant dernière
question là il y a une pression
économique énorme parce que ça
n'intéresse absolument pas
au grand capital pharmaceutique mondiale
qui ont pu savoir des productions par
l'État
de n'importe quel médicament de
n'importe quel vaccin d'ailleurs mais
les vaccins dont le monde de la ce qu'on
appelle Big Pharma c'est un truc qu'on
peut nouveau la Big Pharma une bien
faire des médicaments pour garantir la
chronicité des maladies etc
oui oui
et donc si on a dans l'appareil d'État
une institution
qui appartient donc à l'appareil d'État
et qui puisse garantir
la fabrication
de produits pour la santé
que ça soit de diagnostic que ce soit
des vaccins que ce soit de médicaments
de médicaments de synthèse de
médicaments biologiques si on a dans
l'appareil d'État
une garantie de production pas forcément
de 100%, mais
d'une importance pour la population la
question des pénuries
il me semble mais l'expérience n'a pas
été faite donc comme je suis
scientifique je veux pas dire a priori
mais il me semble qu'on serait plus
sauvegarder
de des fluctuations comme ça qui existe
une des choses qu'il a fait au cause a
commencé à faire maintenant c'est dans
la chaîne de thérapie génique produire
des A à Z tout
justement pour ne pas être
otage de la production privée
internationale
donc je pense que cette notion
de dans l'état avoir une esthéticition
qui soit capable de garantir ça
il me semble que c'est une notion
centrale
et à partir de là
les choix des médicaments qui seront
produits ça ne passe absolument pas par
le profit
ça passe par le besoin de la population
et à partir d'un noyau
d'intelligence au sein de l'État
et bien évidemment à partir de la
compétence de fabrication de ces
produits on va choisir par exemple
des anti-accroviraux des anti-cancer la
fécose en particulier produit ça des
anti-diabètes des anti et des
antihypersensiaux
le choix il passe par une étude
épidémiologique bien entendu donc le
choix il passe par la science tout
d'abord la science en tant
qu'épidémiologie en tant que faire la
cartographie de ce qui se passe sur le
plan de pathologies dans le pays
et quand on a et c'est pour ça que
depuis la première diapositive que je
montrais quand on a une
insuffisance stratégique qui est dans
l'appareil d'État à l'intérieur de
l'appareil d'État
tout devient beaucoup plus simple
même dans un pays avec beaucoup
d'inégalités avec par exemple nous avons
eu dans les dernières années une
décroissance
d'investissement en santé ça a été
démontré ça il y a quelques jours
d'ailleurs
mais bon d'abord on remonte
la bonne nouvelle mais surtout on a
quand même gardé cette institution au 7
les institutions parce que faut quand
même pas oublier d'autres y compris
l'Institut de temps qui sont des
institutions publiques
et qui peuvent garantir
une certaine autonomie
parce qu'elle s'appartient à l'état
alors la furthrose un modèle très
curieuse je dirais en étant une
institution publique
appartenant au ministère de la Santé
elle après de demandes Vénus de
ministère de la Santé elle fabrique ce
qu'elle doit fabriquer il y a le vent au
ministère de la Santé
et le produit de cette vente
revient à la féroce
par ailleurs est interdite d'évander de
vendre dans le privé
dans le privé
le client de la Focus au Brésil c'est le
ministère de la Santé continentale
donc on n'a pas droit et on ne veut pas
d'ailleurs mais on n'a pas droit de
faire des ventes dans le système privé
de santé
ce qu'on a droit c'est de vendre à des
prix très très bas à d'autres pays à
d'autres gouvernements par exemple le
vaccin contre la fièvre jaune en levant
à quelques pays d'Afrique depuis
longtemps mais on va au gouvernement et
pas du tout à une entreprise privée qui
se situe dans n'importe quel pays autre
et ça je pense que c'est une énorme
différence
dans la construction et dans la
soustabilité
d'un programme pour un pays qui est
énorme
donc
je crois avoir
répondu plusieurs de vos questions
il y a une question à laquelle vous
n'avez pas répondu c'est le fait que
vous vous avez besoin de matière
première qui ne viennent pas du Brésil
et donc à partir de là vous êtes
dépendant d'autres pays et si vous êtes
dépendant d'autres pays vous allez être
tributaire
de des fluctuations et donc vous pouvez
vivre vous avez vécu des pénuries donc
comment ça s'est passé et deuxième
question comment vous faites justement
pour sécuriser vos productions et faire
en sorte de ne pas
dépendre d'autres de pays tiers dans les
matières premières
mais il y a une partie de cette question
que je pourrais répondre et à une autre
que je ne pourrais pas répondre par
ignorance faut le dire c'est pas parce
que c'est un mystère c'est juste par
ignorance
[Musique]
dans le cadre de médicaments de synthèse
et même de biologique
bon nous avons
presque toute la chaîne de production
mais il y a quelques produits qui
effectivement il faut acheter dans le
marché mondial
on a vécu ça
pour les vaccins
de covid parce qu'il y avait au début
après non mais au début parce que ça a
été
bon je pense que vous avez suivi ça a
été une horreur internationale est-ce
que c'est passé sur le plan
économique de
on a eu en avion brésilien
qui transportait du matériel qui a été
pris en otage dans un pays
il me semble que c'était un Inde
tous les produits ont été débarqués et
embarqués pour les États-Unis on a eu ça
on a vécu ça
donc
mais
je ne vois pas pour l'instant je n'ai
pas vu j'ai pas vu c'est pour ça que je
dis
il y a une question d'ignorance de ma
part personnelle mais j'ai pas vu dans
le cadre des produits de synthèse et
même des produits qui font partie du
portfolio de
produits biothérapeutique produit par la
bioco qui en a eu cette pénurie à point
de ne pas pouvoir de ne pas pouvoir
produire or il y a tout de même une
chose que je voudrais signaler
et qui n'a rien à voir avec
le marché mondial
si on peut dire comme ça c'était le
marché interne c'est à dire que un
moment donné
la demande du gouvernement pour les
produits de synthèse pour des
médicaments de synthèse à diminuer
beaucoup
autrement dit la production a été
diminuée parce qu'il y avait plein de
demandes pas parce qu'il y avait pas de
condition de produire mais parce que il
y avait pas de demande et bien entendu
comme n'importe quel médicament il faut
produire à partir d'une certaine demande
parce qu'autrement on va jeter à la
poubelle après
et donc ça on a vécu mais par des
raisons autre et pas de fait que dans le
marché international on n'avait pas le
produit de base pour acheter
est-ce que chers collègues vous avez des
questions complémentaires
non moi je voulais vous remercier parce
que c'est extrêmement intéressant comme
témoignage et reposer peut-être les
questions très précises quand poser
Laurence sur
en particulier sur le problème des
brevets parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a une protection des brevets des
bicarma sont protégés par ces brevets
pendant 8 10 12 ans et puis il se
débrouille pour avoir sur une indication
complémentaire ils ont obtenir le brevet
sur un an de plus ou six mois ou 18 mois
et c'est vraiment un argument qu'on nous
oppose très souvent dans les difficultés
que l'on a aujourd'hui donc Laurent ça
avait posé la question et j'aimerais
vraiment que vous y répondiez de de
façon précise alors sur la sécurité par
rapport
j'allais dire sur le par rapport au Big
Pharma on voit bien que c'est parce que
c'est une institution nationale qui
appartient au gouvernement qui est une
institution de l'État que vous devez
résister j'allais dire quelque part au
Big Pharma ce qui est pas le cas par
tout ailleurs j'allais dire enfin en
tout cas presque partout ailleurs dans
dans le monde ce qui nous va nous poser
question sur le modèle que l'on pourrait
éventuellement préconiser suite à cette
commission d'enquête
voilà c'était surtout par rapport à ses
brevets parce que c'est quelque chose
qui nous est opposé très très souvent
Corinne Imbert excusez-moi
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur
[Musique]
la Fondation
travaille avec un souci de l'innovation
aussi mais est-ce qu'il vous arrive
aussi
d'acheter des médicaments innovants à
d'autres pays
et qu'elle est dans ces cas-là en fait
quelle est la
pour faire essayer de comparer un petit
peu ce qui se passe en France et ce qui
se passe dans votre pays en tout cas
d'avoir une appréciation
est-ce que vous avez fait le choix de
l'innovation
au détriment des médicaments anciens ce
qu'on appelle les médicaments matures
dans notre pays est-ce que vous achetez
des principes actifs innovants à des
sociétés étrangères des laboratoires
étrangers pour fabriquer le médicament
et le mettre à disposition
de votre population
et dans ces cas-là sans dévoiler des
secrets d'affaires mais quel est quel
est le la façon dont vous négocier tout
ça pour que ça soit acceptable pour
votre système de santé
sur le plan financier bien sûr
allez-y
merci pour les questions et puis je
m'excuse pour ne pas avoir répondu
l'histoire du brevet avant
or
sur le plan des produits de synthèse
on produit des génériques autrement dit
leur brevet est parti depuis longtemps
déjà donc on a le droit de produire et
on produit
et une grande partie et alors j'ai
oublié de vous dire mais ces produits de
synthèse ils vont aussi directement
au système de santé au système initié de
santé
ils sont distribués dans un réseau
national ce qu'on appelle pharmacie
populaire et ce sont des pharmacies
privées nos réseaux privés
auquel le gouvernement
fournit
toute une série de médicaments
dégénériques qui sont produits par
différentes entreprises brésiliennes
dont la furose mais il y a aussi du
privé qui produit des génériques au
Brésil mais la Focus produit en partie
et cette pharmacie populaire des livres
des médicaments gratuitement il suffit
d'avoir une ordonnance
vous savez quelle est la part des
médicaments génériques produites par la
fiocrousse par rapport à 40%
par ailleurs sur des produits qui n'ont
dans le brevet
est encore valable
si on a une décision
et cette décision elle est prise
à partir du département du secrétariat
au sein du ministère de la Santé je
secrétariat des sciences technologiques
innovation en santé
un accord avec la Focus
et des fois on fait des accords
des partenaires partenariats publics
privés de transfert des technologies de
production
comme ça a été le cas que je montrais de
du vaccin anti covid
donc il y a quelques partenariats de
production des bio pharmaceutiques qui
ont été faits comme ça
et comment ça se fait bah ça se fait par
une
une entreprise privée qui a devant elle
une entreprise publique et pour venir à
votre question de résistance à la Big
Pharma
c'est-à-dire que on est un ministère de
la Santé qui a quand même une énorme
d'un pays de 220 000 personnes
et puis et puis la fiocrousse est dans
les cinq premières
production
institution de pharma au Brésil
la production
est presque une big pharma
et par rapport
au pays et donc l'empereur
donc
comme j'avais dit dans la loi
brésilienne il y a
ça écrit dans la Constitution qui qui la
santé est en droit du citoyen et un
devoir l'état or à partir de là
des médicaments pour des maladies rares
qui sont hyper cher
et encore une fois les maladies rares
dans un pays de 220 millions de
personnes elles sont rares mais il y en
a beaucoup de gens qui ont ces maladies
non mais c'est vrai
et ça coûte
trop cher mais
il vaut mieux faire tous les sacrifices
possibles et garder quand même le droit
du citoyen la santé
et c'est bien pour cela que CROUS va
commencer à développer toute une
technologie pour produire des
médicaments pour les maladies rares
début
pour les maladies
des cortisselles on est en train de
faire un accord avec une
c'est pas une big pharma mais c'est
quand même une entreprise privée
américaine
issue de l'université
transférer la méthodologie mais quand on
dit transférer la méthodologie c'est à
dire que après on devient autonome
c'est à dire que la transfert des
technologies n'est pas simplement
l'achat de la technologie c'est vraiment
le transfert à partir et afin duquel on
devient complètement autonome
et pour l'innovation c'est à dire que
pardon
excusez-moi je disais que c'était un
modèle qu'on utilisait en industrie pour
Airbus avec les Chinois par exemple on a
fait des transferts de technologie
le modèle de train excusez-moi de
transfert de technologie pour être
ensuite autonome c'est un des problèmes
qui se pose par exemple à Airbus qui a
transféré des technologies à la Chine et
qui est aujourd'hui capable de fabriquer
des Airbus quoi c'est un problème
par exemple vous savez
il y a dans beaucoup de
technologie de pour thérapie génique
la production
d'une structure qui se ressemble à un
virus qui s'appelle ave qui est la
France produit on peut etc nous on
produit pas au Brésil et ça sera pas
pour la Focus et c'est pour la fécose
une priorité une priorité immédiate
d'avoir l'autonomie de production parce
que sans ça on sera jamais autonome dans
la thérapie elle-même
donc je fête qu'on peut avoir cette
chaîne
de l'innovation de la recherche
à travers l'innovation jusqu'à la
production
c'est ça que nous qui représente la
force des frappes
d'État vis-à-vis tout ce qu'il y a en
tant que
alternative privé quoi
mais on joue c'est à dire que
entre le public et le privé il y a
toujours une fossé quand même pas
négligeable donc on joue tout le temps
pour qu'on prenne bien
parce qu'un transfert de technologie
irrém messager c'est quand même pas rien
c'est comme si c'est comme avoir le
brevet quelque part donc on comprend
bien que il y a un engagement de la part
de la fiocrousse de pas être de pas
aller sur des marchés concurrentiels du
laboratoire or le pays or le Brésil
c'est que pour certains vous avez des
autorisations de fournir pour quelques
médicaments mais pas tout par exemple en
Afrique comme vous l'avez dit pour pour
certains vaccins
mais donc j'imagine que dans le
transfert de technologie il y a cette ce
contrat là de pas concurrencer en dehors
il n'empêche qu'on se pose quand même la
question de l'intérêt car le laboratoire
de vous transférer la technologie RN
messager dans la mesure où le grand
espoir de la RN messager c'est sa
capacité à se dupliquer à l'infini face
à des virus nombreux voire de pouvoir
être polyvalent sur plusieurs virus
puisque c'est ça le développement à
venir sans compter les implications qui
pourraient se voir en cancérologie ou
pour d'autres pathologies et donc on
essaie de comprendre pourquoi c'est quoi
la contrepartie ou l'intérêt pour le
laboratoire de vous transférer la
technologie
je vois deux choses un peu différentes
dans votre question
la technologie
des ARN messager elle est elle est déjà
un peu répandue dans le monde mais il y
a très peu de gens qui le font le choix
c'était un choix de
pour que la fiouse qui a la capacité
déjà installé de le faire
parce que on a déjà de vaccins en cours
au niveau expérimental en prenant cette
méthodologie
donc la choucroute a été choisie
dans l'Amérique du Sud parce que elle
possède déjà la technologie pour le
faire
donc on n'aura pas à transférer quoi que
ce soit à partir de cette technologie
donc
vous puissiez acquérir qui qui a imposé
contenu du contexte de pandémie mondial
que la technologie vous soit transférée
non pas tout à fait
non on a développé la technologie quand
même nous-mêmes
l'OMS a fait
le milieu de l'année à la fin de l'année
dernière c'était reconnaître quelques
centres
sur la planète qui était capable était
déjà capable de faire ça il a fait au
cours c'était un de ses centres
mais de toute façon la question elle est
pertinente la question de à quoi ça sert
de faire pour une big pharma quoi ça
sert
et ben je ne sais pas exactement
mais je sais
quelque part et là je vais vous dire
encore une fois par Nuance je fais pas
partie de discussion du marché mais je
sais qu'il est discussions avec
AstraZeneca ont été des discussions très
dures très très dur
mais pour insta par exemple le fait
d'avoir
le Brésil
distribuer
et ça a été il y avait une clause pour
le Brésil comme vous avez signalé
distribuer ça pour astrazeneka qui
n'avait pas
une histoire consistante de vente des
vaccins
ça a été une ouverture d'un univers donc
donc sur le plan de la politique
et sur le plan du
de la visibilité dans le marché mondial
ça a été un investissement pour à ces
années aussi
ça c'est sûr
et le transfert de technologie il s'est
fait
de façon financière ou on vous demande
pas le montant on le demandera en rush
mais c'était un transfert financier
financé par l'État brésilien d'accord
à partir du secrétariat des sciences
technologiques innovation du ministère
alors nous à part les donations pendant
la pandémie qui en a eu beaucoup de
donations du privé la fiouse fonctionne
avec l'argent public
je sais pas si vous avez d'autres
questions
bien j'espère que je peux être utile
une je sais que il y a une recherche de
de comment dirais-je de coopération avec
avec la France
entre la fiou Cruz et la France et
cette coopération vous travaillez plutôt
sur quoi sur la recherche sur
sur
la lutte
contre les pénuries de médicaments sur
il y a quelque chose de particulier ou
pas
il y a plusieurs volets différents
qui sont convergents dans la réponse à
votre question
d'abord il y a une histoire
il a une histoire
très profonde entre la coopération du
Brésil avec la France d'une façon plus
générale en particulier dans le domaine
biomédical mais d'une façon plus
générale la coopération du Brésil avec
la France en mathématiques et énorme
depuis très longtemps
donc il y a ce côté historique qui est
très important
il y a
donc le fait qu'il y a ce côté
historique il y a des liens qui qui
existent et là je vous donne un exemple
[Musique]
l'Institut Pasteur a une coopération
avec la Focus depuis la naissance de la
circule
maintenant depuis quelques donc la
coopération elle est basée sur la
science
mais elle est basée sur la recherche
mais et là je parle du Brésil en général
et la fille en particulier
il y a des dispositifs de coopération
franco-brésiliennes spécifiques comme
par exemple un programme de déplacement
d'étudiants et des chercheurs qui
s'appelle capisco c'est un programme qui
a
40 ans déjà
il y en a d'autres
il n'y a pas que ça mais alors je
reviens sur la focrose la Focus j'avais
dit mais d'une façon très rapide et très
superficielle
qui est la fille Rose a pris une
décision d'un centre internationaliser
beaucoup plus que jusqu'à présent
et donc
d'ici
deux semaines probablement au 3 la
fiocross qui a un accord avec l'Institut
Pasteur plus générale va passer un
accord que sur l'innovation
oui dans le domaine biomédical
on est en train de chercher
un endroit où éventuellement bon nous
avons des laboratoires de cherche
associés
par exemple il est en labo
Sorbonne financée par l'islam
mais
dans ce cadre
de cette nouvelle étape
d'internationalisation de la piochos on
cherche
d'endroit où on puisse
monter un laboratoire de la Focus
on commence à discuter par exemple au
niveau du génome
et en faisant en partenariat privé avec
trop possiblement si jamais ça marche ça
c'est en cours
et c'est loin d'être fini
mais si ça marche ça sera autour des
thérapies cellulaires thérapie génique
etc parce que il y a une décision du
gouvernement dans la philo sera le bras
qui va développer ça de faire des
thérapies je m'appelle thérapie avancée
dans ce cadre stratégique
il est question que la fiocrisse
puisse ouvrir un bureau et s'établir de
façon plus à long terme ici en France ça
sera pas que en France la même chose
passe au Portugal à la même espace un
peu et l'idée c'est que la Focus puisse
avoir quelques bureaux qui vont
fonctionner comme
plaque tournante et à la fois
facilitateur de nouvelles collaborations
dans différents pays stratégiques
dans la France fait partie
posez juste une dernière question comme
ça de la question du budget de la fiou
Cruz vous savez un montant pour le
budget parce que on voit 13000 13000
personnes qui travaillent pour la fille
au Cruz une grosse part essentiellement
des finances publiques j'imagine que
vous avez du mécénat peut-être ou très
peu donc vraiment pas de dépendance
voilà et donc avoir une idée pendant la
pandémie c'était vraiment l'exception
mais ça nous a permis de construire
l'hôpital de connaître le montant global
enfin le budget de la fiocrose
en milliards
et voilà cette présentation d'un système
qui
on dit toujours que la question de de
des politiques publiques de santé dans
leur dimension
réellement public
[Musique]
ça peut marcher pour des petits pays moi
pour des gros la 200 millions
d'habitants donc c'est intéressant
d'avoir eu cette présentation merci
beaucoup j'espère que je peux être utile
pour vous
et je m'excuse pour des questions que
j'ai pas pu répondre
c'était un plaisir de toute façon